and biology is really really tough
on one hand
um
but it's also very uh rewarding you know
now we work in clinical programs that
wow um we were able to show that we
correct the disease in patient-derived
cells in a genetic
you know very severe genetic disease
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthred excel today we're
going to be diving deep into biotech and
intellectual property meet rachel
diamond chief ip officer and head of
pipeline development of amendo
biotherapeutics amanda was founded in
2015 by rachel and a group of classmates
from weitzman harold amando as chief
intellectual property officer and head
of pipeline development includes
designing an iep strategy for a mendo
that both generates an extensive patent
portfolio to cover various novel aspects
of the technology and products and also
navigates the ip space
additionally she is building a mendo's
pipeline of clinical programs and the
academic and industrial collaborations
and partnerships for the pre-clinical
development of amendo's selected
indications and genomic targets
rachel diamond welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm very well thank you how are you
doing this morning
i i'm doing wonderful i'm so excited to
be talking to you about amendo and bio
therapeutics and the i the role of
intellectual property within
within biotech and uh gene editing and
there's so much to talk about you have a
phenomenal journey behind you from a
biotech engineering from the technion
masters in neuroscience from weitzman
institute of science you are now you
have you've co-founded a mendo with
classmates from the weizmann institute
after being a serial entrepreneur with a
few other companies
that are that are also just incredible
that are dealing with with similar
topics
rachel before we dive into
biotherapeutics and what you're doing
with the mendo can you briefly mention a
few of the key milestones on your
journey but from the lenses of of of how
they helped you progress either as an
entrepreneur or a leader
yeah absolutely so
yeah so first of all the academic
background i guess that's uh um
especially in engineering when i went
into the field of also medical device
and biotech it gave me a lot of
flexibility to understand
um you know complex systems like mris
and and and heavy technology uh on the
engineering side so my education was
very helpful and helped me stay very
versatile with the you know the fields i
was able to uh dive into
um so i guess that's that's one point i
think um the other would be probably
when i started working at shiba medical
center in the um
technology transfer unit where i first
dived into the world of iep strategy and
really how to construct an ib portfolio
that would make sense and would generate
value and i could also understand why
there are like you know um what's
missing in this field why it's not
always
being done in an optimized way um and
that also helped me to
you know to develop
to to master that and to really develop
my own
capabilities around that
which is really a key point also in our
discussion
um
and maybe also as a child my father is a
physician and now he's a surgeon
and i was always very interested and
very intrigued by the human body and and
and biology
uh but also medical systems and to
understand how that world uh operates so
it all came together uh during the years
to uh to where i am right now
amazing so let's start from the
intellectual property side which which
you're dealing with today because i
think it's an interesting question to be
asked when you're developing deep
technology or something that is
um you know that is really core to the
value of an organization or a company
what what is this what is sort of the
struggle or the constraints in terms of
intellectual property in the biotech
space and what is the role of the ip
strategist in protecting that domain
expertise in your company
yeah absolutely and it's very important
um
so i think i think often and i saw
you know numerous examples of of that
um ip at companies is usually handled
in a crooked way so you know you the
companies develop technology and they
have really cool and and and and novel
technology and then they go to the
patent attorney and the patent attorney
writes a patent on the technology
and if you do if you do it that way you
would
more often than not i don't want to
generalize but more often than not you
will not get a good patent that really
helps you that really generates value
because
patents are not about writing or you
know
of technology it's about being really a
business tool and you have to ask the
right questions before you go and draft
a patent so you really have to ask
what's the product who will who will be
buying the product where we where will
you be making the product so these
specific questions if they're not asked
or not analyzed
usually you'd get a patent that covers
maybe covers the technology but doesn't
cover the product and product and
technology are often not the same they
may be overlapping but your patents have
to be directed to the product the way
it's gonna be designed its final design
and you know the different components
that's going to be in it and what you're
actually going to be selling i can give
you like an example this was really like
you know mind-blowing for me when i
realized that so
um so for example in the in the uh
glucose sensing space you have companies
developing glucose sensors
and
writing all the patents because the
technology is in the glucose sensor it's
in the sensor
but then you find out that they're
actually not selling the sensor they're
giving it away for free and their entire
business model is based on the strips on
the the strips that they're selling and
there's no patent covering that to know
and and and so this is where you see
that the patents don't cover the actual
product that the company is selling and
that happens a lot more often than not
and it's it's uh it's fascinating
because um you know the patents are like
the major assets of the company it's the
value driving
and
if it's not directed correctly to
to the actual product to the components
to what's going to be in the final
product that gets that's the company is
selling you don't get valuable patents
actually these patents are often not
enforceable not protectable
and
they're just off
right i think you know we're in 2021 and
i think a lot of the conversation
has shifted from patents you know when
i'm looking at a lot of my friends
leaving university or 8200
i don't think many of them are thinking
about patenting their technology and
perhaps that is because a lot of it is
software based but are we are we
shifting away from patents and
intellectual property holding or or is
it just that
the
the domain that i'm living in is is
having is has less of that but it's
still very much
considered reputable and biotech yeah
yeah so yeah so i think
you're right in software uh it is moving
away from patents they they used to
write a lot of patents and software but
it really doesn't have a lot of value so
and and you disclose a lot um and and
your your ability to really uh enforce
those patents is really low so
so yes software is really moving away
from patents but in the technology world
intangible technology definitely patents
are still ruling big time and getting
even more and more strong um
yeah
that makes a lot of sense and so tell me
a little bit about your
entrepreneurial journey within biotech
and i want you to start with
what is biotech from your lens and as
you're going through the technion and
then you're diving into neuroscience at
weizmann
what are some of the convictions that
you understand
that you're going to employ as a
strategy as an entrepreneur
so i guess at the time i wasn't uh i i
really didn't know what i was going to
do i was just fascinated by the
the field and the technology and the
biology um i didn't i didn't know what i
was going to do with this
um i'm very entrepreneurial but you know
that's my
that's my my nature and
uh so i was always like you know looking
around to see what's going on and and uh
started working at chiba medical center
which brought a lot of innovation to my
table uh which was also really really
interesting uh and the processes inside
the hospital how to develop a project so
i was exposed to that um entrepreneurial
um you know
ventures from my role as ip
from the ip side
um and then when i when i started
working with david barra my good friend
from school uh we're you know we he's my
classmate and we were good friends from
the very beginning um from the first day
of school at the fire drill
we got together and i guess we're good
friends ever since
and when i started working with him 10
years ago or a bit more
again started on the ip side but i think
we are very similar in the way we think
and that we're very similar in in our
ambitious and so it was kind of natural
to start to start you know developing
projects together um david is a super
talented entrepreneur a brilliant
scientist and a brilliant businessman
and
so it's just you know it was a lot of
fun we were having a lot of fun doing
you know the work and um working
together so synergistically
uh so we started you know more and more
projects and moving forward in this
world of of
establishing companies and and taking
technology forward
uh and funding it and you know all these
challenges uh of of this space
amazing
i'm really really fortunate to work with
such a
amazing amazing people who are my close
friends as well
wonderful okay so
amando
jeans
tell me a little bit about the problem
space and and how you're tackling it
um so it really started um so you know
david comes from uh from adionats lab
and
so he's he comes from structure function
of proteins and protein
and protein engineering
and then we also
started working together with lior who
just came back from harvard from his
postdoc and he came with this world of
of dna repair and dna damage response uh
and also noam who's uh also from the
same lab doing from the world of dna
repair and together we kind of realized
that if we take the current tools like
crispr basically
and and combine it with protein
engineering we can actually do um a lot
of a lot of improvements and a lot of
progress in the field because protein
engineering is very powerful methodology
if you want to take proteins and you
want to evolve them and change their
properties and make them better adapted
to what they're supposed to do so you
know crispr is like it's a it's a tool
that came from bacteria it's an immune
system of bacteria and it was never
designed to work in the mammalian cell
context so if you want to take a protein
from one context where it was evolved in
evolution for millions of years and you
want to take it into a new context you
need to make adjustments you need to
change it
and this is what we decided that we're
going to do with protein engineering
it's it's a methodology called directed
evolution where you actually take a
protein you introduce changes
and you screen what happened with those
changes to see how how did you change
the protein so you see
you put up essays that will help you
screen those those um
those variants and really be able to
select those specific variants that have
improved characteristics
and then you continue with that variance
to develop
cure to develop genetic genetic
medicines
so i know very very little about what
you're talking about but that sounds
fascinating and and i love the phrase
direct evolution um
how much of it is you know when you're
trying to simulate what would happen
given the change in protein over over
scale and and over evolution how much of
it is software based simulations versus
physical ones
um so
it started on the physical side we
started by setting up the uh um
you know generating protein libraries
these are really large libraries we
these are ten in the ninth
um large
libraries of protein variants that you
wanna screen
uh so you know the the the screening
procedure and and the essays that
reports are really important
um
but only at a later stage i guess only
after um
i guess almost two years after this
company started we really uh we really
started building also our
what is called bioinformatics
which is
the software people
coming in and
analyzing this huge amount of data that
we're generating and starting to
building models and to do predictions
and to
um
and and today we have actually a really
really wonderful and very very
professional
unit of uh bioinformatics now with um of
like six phds in that field
that are writing codes for and and you
know really um
for street also for streamlining our
work but also for extracting um insights
from this huge amount of data we're
generating so amazing this is really
fascinating um process
and so maybe you know i think one of the
most impactful things i can get out of
this also is this understanding of what
it means to create a biotech company one
of the companies that i've been most
fascinated by recently is immunized by
two good friends and and you know i've
been asking myself
what what is it like running in a
biotech company as an entrepreneur or as
a serial entrepreneur in your case
in comparison to that of a traditional
b2b sas and cyber or traditional ai
can you walk me through some of the big
milestones that you would experience as
an entrepreneur in deep technology
biotech space
um
yeah so you know i think it's very
different because biology is very
challenging and you never know if it's
gonna work
you never know it's not like in software
you you you decide to do something and
then you have to just make it you know
but there's no not a lot of
of
a mystery around if it's going to work
or not you just generate what you want
you know what you want to do you have
some people computers whatever and and
you just do it um and in biology there's
a lot of unknown and a lot of uh work
that needs to put into
setting up the right systems that will
report correctly on what you want to see
and there's also you know there's always
the unknown will we find the solution
will we have it you know we don't know
will it work will it and also you know
you work in this in in in the context of
human disease
so
you're also very much dependent on the
literature and what is already known the
mechanism is it fully elucidated
do you know exactly what you're going to
do in the human cell once you do the
genome editing what will be the outcome
will you be able to fix the phenotype to
correct the disease so there's a lot of
unknowns and
biology is really really tough
on one hand
but it's also very rewarding you know
now we work in clinical programs that
wow
we were able to show that we correct the
disease in patient derived cells in a
genetic
you know very severe genetic disease
that children have so
when you're able to develop a cure for
that it is um it is actually
crazy
and how early in your life did you know
that this is the world you're going to
be living in
oh very early on you know i was i was
sitting with my dad for hours um asking
him about the digestion system and the
cns and how things work in the body
um i think biology was always i had no
question in my mind that that this is
what i'm going to do when i grow up
i thought to be a physician at first
but then i realized that this is not
what i want to do
um i think the also i guess for my
father uh realizing that the system is
very um
very challenging you know the the
medical system to working as a physician
is very challenging and you um you're
very constrained so
and i also love the technology so
i took on a different direction
you know very very cool engineering
would be would be good which it really
was
really i want to spend the last few
minutes continuing on this on the same
path and understanding you a little bit
better
and go so going back to the childhood
you know what what part of this really
was the fascinating aspect here was it
the you know the unknown was it the
uncovering was it the actual you know
the medical side of things the impact
that it could have
um so i guess yeah it's the medical side
of things and
um
and really understanding how the body
works from the organ level to the
cellular level to the molecular level
you know it's really just amazing
and
um and i think that also drove me in
another direction that i'm very
interested in and i i spent a lot of
time um you know reading and
understanding
um nutrition and health and and
supplements and etc because this
you know under coming from the science
and understanding the biochemistry and
understanding physiology and
metabolism
then it connects to how the world really
works and you know what impacts our body
environmental factors nutritional
factors and i've been able to also you
know affect my own health
as well as my friends you know everyone
who's close to knows that
eating like eating junk food around me
is not a very recommended
situation
amazing amazing and and what in what is
what inspires you today as you go about
your journey in your day-to-day when
you're working with jeans or in any of
your other biotech companies
um sorry go again my my kids just got in
what inspires you today
you know in your day-to-day life either
as you're working on genes or biotech in
general
um
so i think you know innovation and like
ground-breaking innovation
is um
is really mind-blowing and
whenever we find solutions that are
completely novel
and
very effective
then
then this is uh
yeah then this is mind-blowing this is
so
i think that's what inspires me today
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i think um
innovator
um
i'm also
optimistic
and relentless
i love it rachel thank you very
much i hope that you go ahead and make a
huge positive impact with everything
that you do i really appreciate your
time
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
yeah you too thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
you